he even Japan quite a lot right a lot
he's seven times in five years seven
times seven times that's appropriate I
just went to Japan for the first time
and played resonable seven for about
four hours that would have worked out
better if I play it for seven hours I
almost went to Japan seven times so what
do u @ly do you want your zero he's been
to Japan 0 times yeah but I almost 17
times so this is dead air Mike mihari
your host and my headphones on Pete
Brown you've been here a lot before Jake
Decker you been on the show before
Marrakech switching the video there's
like our third episode on video uh yeah
I skipped one cuz I'm uh lazy yeah I
don't know I don't know we always say I
played a lot of resin evil 7 Capcom in
Osaka Japan just pretty much gave us
access to about an hour into the game
and just to play straight from there
there's the most anybody seen the game
yet and after those two demos people are
kind of wondering what the game is gonna
be all about its gonna be like outlast
can be amnesia I can say with great
confidence is very much a resident evil
gamers combat there's item management it
feels very much like what we'll get into
it it's a traditional resonable game and
I'm really excited about it I haven't
played the whole team it like I said
four hours of it uh it's it's looking
good and I'm pumped about it so we want
to do like an entire episode just like
asking me questions or me talking about
it we have like a if you're like coming
to dad like ask me questions about
resonable seven no I think you've talked
enough all right good go go ask me more
questions my dad porn and I Ukraine on
this the 56th Lord of our 20th year six
Lord yeah of our twentieth year yeah
Harvest Moon all those things um I got a
better question let's start with one of
those uh let's talk about this resident
evil like everyone stoked about it and I
got to pick Mike's brain a little bit as
soon as you got back and something I
wanted to ask was um how much like the
original trilogy is this game like are
we going back to our roots here yeah
that's actually like kind of in a
nutshell how I described the damn i
played it feels like res evil remake in
first person
by that I mean like a lot of people were
hoping I was hoping res evil stuff would
go back to the series roots I and I
again I just thought that would be
wishful thinking but it seems like
Capcom's finally just like saying [ __ ]
it let's do it you know this item
management you have green herbs you're
combining with chem fluids for health
your scavenging every possible thing to
help you throughout this mansion that
you start off in which again feels very
much like Spencer mansion from res evil
is mansion accurate is it that big it's
a match it's like a it's a yeah it's
like a mansion on in a state ok so it's
I wouldn't say it's as big as Spencer
mansion but it's yeah it's this pretty
large house I'm gonna one-up the
Spencer's man no Oswald Spencer yeah uh
the third and the architect for his name
you just threw me off ya know they're
employed right flank or frankly it's an
entire plantation in the American South
again there aren't too many connections
to the resinous storyline but you do
come across them but it feels a little
more grounded they're not zombies
crawling across it but what enemies you
do run into it's pretty scary and you
know you like hope you prepared enough
up until that point feels a lot like res
evil 3 nemesis which Mary and I are
playing through right now and in in that
like the boss is before you actually
fight them I saw two boss fights or I
fought two bosses I don't want to get it
too much in taxes kind of a sport or
what I meant but you actually are being
hunted by these people for like much of
the demo I played in much of the game
again the demo I played start about an
hour in right around that dinner scene
from the trailer that capcom released
where the baker family were kind of as
feasting on human organs and then you
escaped and you kind of start going
around this house and it feels like the
mansion from the original game or the
police station resonable two or three in
that you're finding these keys to get to
specific areas i know the overused term
is Metroidvania but it's more like the
resident original residen evil like I
got the scorpion key so now I can go
into this bedroom and this basement
hallway which led me to this key which
would let me get to the rest of the
house and I have to go outside to the
greenhouse or the shack and that would
let me come back into the mansion and
get like the grenade launcher it's
awesome it feels like one big puzzle
it's like slow pace but pretty like
confident feeling
it doesn't feel you know there's no
quick time events explosions were few
and far between as opposed to six yeah
you're not going to be like blowing up
where was it Kowloon in res evil 6 as
Chris Redfield is Kowloon the city and
uh oh I didn't finish that game but in
the real world cat is it Kowloon that
abandoned Kowloon is a real place is
that the abandoned city in China Oh in
hong kong in hong kong maybe that's what
it was yeah it was like that very dense
sort of like apartment thing that was I
think stripped away like in the late 80s
or something like that but people have
like wire up their own electricity like
they never saw sunlight like it was a
crazy little mini civilization that's
creepy yeah it's not like there are some
influences from like resonable for like
in terms of maybe I don't of the action
because you are its its first person
obviously in VR I played it for about an
hour and VR and you're aiming with your
eyes and the reticle just follows where
your eyesight is so let me ask you about
first person because that's a pretty big
shift and does that feel unnatural any
point and does it does that make it feel
not like Resident Evil despite all the
mechanical similarities a little bit
yeah you don't have the same situational
awareness that you did in the first
games but obviously the first games were
fixed camera angles which was just a way
to get around the technology the time
but that became was more than that yeah
but it became like it became you know
like you walk into a room there be a
zombie behind you you'd have to actually
figure out like how to dodge them and
like some room to play with that there
be a mirror here that make you go the
wrong way right away but it would
actually I don't know res evil 7 felt I
did feel more control but i think they
designed the mansion well enough so your
sight lines are always kind of like
there'd be like a certain corner that's
darken and it's something would come out
of it or they'd be like the basement was
pretty maze like they did a pretty good
job of not making me feel overpowered
despite the fact that it felt it doesn't
feel like it's just a first person
shooter like it might be like titanfall
or something like there's weapons way
it's you know like it feels like a dude
who doesn't usually use guns that just
picked one up it doesn't feel like
you're you're not a member of the Stars
team like in the original ones um what
about the the atmosphere is everything
we've seen so far is like pretty drab
and like I understand that fits the tone
and like the story behind the family but
is it visually like that like brown and
kind of shadowy like throughout the
whole mansion shadowy yeah there was I
don't know like some of the screenshots
they sent us showed it like the Sun
coming up or going down at one point and
both the VHS tapes like I think we
talked about before it's like the story
is this frame story in which the main
narrative this guy named Ethan and then
within that are these VHS tapes you find
those like the short segments that you
play through but yeah it did it was
pretty dreary the whole time the mansion
was brown you get into the basement it's
just like covered in this mold and from
which these moulders hmm which look like
regenerators from resin go for if you
remember those Mulder from so I the
x-files never watched I wish that wish
were just clones of mouldour I never
watch the x-files that says terrifying
did you play The X Files Mary ah see it
thank you playing m-files I would not
want to I would not want to fight a
bunch of moulders yeah we're getting off
track are you sure that's their names
though that sounds weird lies are some
Oh Spencer on gay spa his last names
like kayln Mulder yeah and we call him
he's like and he's agent Mulder in some
of his agent Mulder 47 yeah anyway go
follow him follow like it they're called
that because they're made of mold I
guess I didn't understand the basements
like covered in this stuff and every
once in a while they have this very
distinct noise they make when they form
so at one point quickly to backtrack
when you realize you have to go into the
basement and reminded me of outlast in
that there's a subtle hint that the key
you need is in the basement here much
like an outlast like Oh to turn the
power on we have to go to the basement
like [ __ ] I don't want to go down yeah
but it shows you it early and there's
noises coming down from there so it
eludes much earlier on also mentally
don't want to go in there also the Baker
family is the residing clan and again
they're the ones from that cutscene uh
this grandma who's sitting in her
wheelchair just like almost like a
comatose the entire time like this this
Texas Chainsaw Massacre basic yeah this
interruption happens and they get up
from the table while you're still tied
and you kind of wriggle and fall out and
then you look over sheet if you walk
around the room like when you are in
total control and the rest of families
around looking her eyes will just follow
you hmm and then you go to the kitchen
come back and she's just gone like
wheelchair and all and later before you
go to the base but she's kind of
Nexus there she'll just randomly show up
when you least expect it I reminded me
of a great garden who do you think's
moving released the documentary now
spoof of greyguard right what were you
gonna say it is stupid but I actually do
have a question yeah so you kind of
mentioned weapons and stuff like that
our weapons like how big of rolled
weapons plex I think that's something
that people were really curious about
like are their firearms and they said
yes there are but it seems more like the
farms or more of a tool to get through
an obstacle or is it like are there some
areas where you just gonna be like you
know going off yeah so you're not like
any you're like this every man guy at
least as far as i know i don't know too
much about him despite the fact that
he's protagonists you're not a star's
character who has like who's like weapon
training but also not just like this
schmuck like you get you're like
crafting ammo like bullets shotgun
shells you know like I'm not supposed to
spoil how you get the shotgun but it's
it's like the earlier games you there's
a puzzle to get it and it's once you get
it you feel a little more I'd like a
throwback to kind of yeah I felt a lot
more powerful when I went into the
basement but it's very much a resident
evil it's you know like outlast any sure
you're powerless you're just there it's
almost like the term now for a lot of
like narrative driven game is walking
simulator whereas like outlast and
amnesia kind of put a horror twist on
that before even a lot of these like
that term started getting coin but no
you're not powerless in this you're
fighting back you're thinking so chem
fluids these items you find you can
either combine it with green herbs to
make health or like other herbs to make
like really good health kits or
gunpowder to make bullets or you know
like shotgun shells and whatnot so it's
actually kind of cool because when I
first went to the basement I saw the
moulders I saw a lot of them like start
to tag me was like I can't hurt them
that much cuz you can get headshots on
them and then they'll hurt more
obviously but I was like I'm gonna get
out of here I went upstairs and like
scavenge for 45 minutes to get as much
as many Kemp loads as I could so then
going back down knowing i still only had
the handgun i'm gonna focus on making
health so i crafted like three health
health packs actually it's this first
day juice i'm not kidding uh there's a
very explicit and specific like cutscene
almost not even cut scene but in game
kind of thing that you see this is
it's called the serum and a big part of
them i played you're trying to make
figure out like the like where it came
from it's essentially like you know like
I'm assuming it's going to go back to
umbrella the Umbrella Corporation at
some point the you know this evil
company that is kind of resided over
proceedings in Resident Evil series for
a long time but it essentially just
allows for crazy rapid regeneration I
miss plants I don't have to you so you
combine chem fluids with the herbs to
make this stuff and then you pour it on
your arm is the meid is the concept of
health juice it's like kombucha you pour
in your arms so like this you've
actually got me like a little bit
worried here and I hope it's not the
case like it sounds like you said this
is a big part of the four hours you
played was kind of coming to terms with
what this stuff is and how to make it it
wasn't a central focus it's just like
eventually there like know not how to
make it so you know what it is right
yeah it seems like it's gonna be kind of
like that that maybe mcguffin's a bad
term but you know like the t-virus the B
virus right but like the whole contract
of this game in my mind is like you're
in a house you need to get out of this
house how the hell do you have time to
even give a [ __ ] about stuff like that
yeah so is it justified it's like you
find out that the serum is instrumental
to like again I don't even know why you
got to this house I started an hour in
you are trying to get out of it and
survived for most of the part but it's
not just like there's definitely a wider
story that i'm not completely familiar
with yet that isn't just this Baker
family kidnapped you and wants you to
become one of the family I don't I don't
know like what the wire story is but
yeah do you think I was like a
journalist and he is going into this
place to classic maneuver like like
outlast or like a lot of things for
everything yeah well because you didn't
know did it bother you at all that you
had to kind of like drop get out of the
mindset of escape and focus on this
thing well i guess like figuring out
what this thing is and how to use it i
like against certain people was
instrumental to escaping from what i
gathered it wasn't like a clearly told
narrative right away um the story itself
like the actual like overarching
narrative didn't strike me as great but
i also
they didn't reveal that many details
kind of sounds like web is gonna come
with the VHS tapes right sure yeah
because you uh it's actually a cool part
where you go in till you play the
lantern demo on the VHS tape is just
slightly different if you play the
lantern demo you're avoiding this Lady
Marguerite in this old shack by the
water and when you make your way to the
shack in the game the first time you do
it if you choose to do VHS tape you
don't have to you play as this girl Mia
I believe and she you kind of see things
from her point of view in the VHS tape
that allow or at least like hint to you
what to do in the present-day narrative
which is pretty cool it's not the first
time games done that it's like it's I
just think it's a cool narrative
technique or just like gameplay
technique almost to help solve puzzles
but yeah it it does kind of feel like
it's that again umbrella corporation
weird just thing being forced on a story
which is kind of a bummer because well I
one hand you want it to fit within the
resin evil story somehow but at the same
time it this is like the most grounded
seemed so far because it's not this
crazy lunatic like philanthropist like
that just kind of got roped into this
corporate espionage it's this crazy
cannibalistic and I think incestuous
family that kidnapped you and I would
just like to escape but yeah because of
the hints provided in the demos about
umbrellas involvement right I would
assume something like that's gonna
happen eventually yeah I don't know but
yeah I'm evil yeah it's very much a
resonable game in terms of like item
management weapon management animal
management oh I got a grenade launcher
to at one point which it looks pretty
advanced it's you're not doing in the
house any well you had to play resin you
will one two three you get a grenade
launcher in those games too you don't
have to use it right you don't want to
use it right away I didn't even like use
it for most my demo yeah but it's doing
there yeah like so much of this sort of
setup seems to be that this family is
like removed from society right like
yeah I love their grenade you're not but
we did for me what I've been able of
design yes that's unclear why that was
Lana cuz a shotgun makes sense a handgun
makes sense these VHS tapes lying around
makes sense even this like these random
just kind of like em flu is lying around
makes sense and drug these others these
drugs that help you see other items in
the environment but I find a lightsaber
to like this is the [ __ ] nuke like
Fat Boy laundry no
first our Peter explain I wish its own
event oh they invented grenade launchers
that's why that yeah exactly it's not
like doom if you played that where you
find a chance on then the little
description says like we honestly don't
know what this is doing on this on Mars
whatever that was kind of endearing but
doom didn't have much it had a story but
it wasn't like they were not taking
themselves too seriously I doubt that
this game is gonna be taking like being
self referential and you know don't make
a joke out of itself it's this is a
scary game so it's trying to like so
give them a grenade launcher Oh give him
a grenade launcher but like it's
interesting because I mean at some point
you do have to be flex with how honest
the world is because you're going to do
surreal things like most resident evils
put you in these ridiculous situations
you know it can't expect me to give me a
hand knife and take down a giant snake I
know but I mean the acid grenade didn't
I from this whole game too but oh my god
leave you think about like them the
moulders mmm you think about mold right
moulders yeah sorry there is like some
sort of justification provided for it
right now I understand like the grenade
launcher could be there to deal with a
big thing but that just seems so out of
place so like the moulders I feel like
there needs to be but there is some like
self-referential stuff in this because
like if you in the original game they
justify all these trapdoors and keys by
it was a crazy philanthropist who
recruited this architect to make it hard
to get around us house cuz you so
paranoid in this game they're almost
like they definitely kidnapped other
people like you find clothes lying
around it's kind of like the road you
come across a house while the closer
sure okay yeah but the the grenade
launcher I don't know how to explain and
the serum stuff I don't know how that
ties in yet but they do in one of these
letters Marguerite the mom says to the
boy I think it's lucas but do not quote
me on that she'll say like in a note say
like okay we've enough people have
escaped the manner that we need to like
make it harder to get like we can't just
rely on them to be tied to a chair we
need to like make it harder to escape do
we know the timeline related to other
games mmm I believe no I can't not
enough to say right now so then it could
be a star's member maybe who got caught
up in there maybe I don't know because
like the original game was you get a
grenade launcher as Claire pretty early
on
on forest body sorry not yeah Claire
Redfield no sorry not Claire Redfield
Jill Valentine you get a grenade
launcher on forest body outside maybe
like she's carrying around whether she
carrying around she got kidnapped by a
bunch of crazies and then they hate her
but she was the Stars member oh but now
it makes sense that she would have a
grenade launcher she always keeps it on
in forest it's her lucky grenade
launchers so as as much as this game
seems grounded at the beginning that
dinner and it is not it more so than
maybe like it's hard to say it's
grounded but there the serum is
definitely like a B virus because
without spoiling much with the boss
fights or anything these boss fights get
really crazy and there is definitely
like regeneration involved ok um and it
they even like your main character like
how the [ __ ] is working you get like you
get a pretty serious injury that nothing
could cure unless you have like I don't
think anything could cure it and
essentially this juice just like cures a
he's like effort to their credit at
least he says what the [ __ ] is happening
sure so not to excuse me I didn't know
it's it's a grenade launcher them I'd
like signals go off in my head yeah yeah
I mean it was like hey reminded me the
first game where is kind of like I have
this grenade launcher but I'm gonna save
it in case I come across this giant
snake or a bunch of these spiders or
whatever what you do in that game or a
giant snake again oh my god um speaking
of which now we're talking about boss
fights I don't wanna get in spoilers i
think you know nobody here wants to know
what's going on but i would like to know
about the difficulty level like how did
you feel playing it and it seems like
you played on the conservative side
where you rewarded for that yeah this
isn't a case of me saying I'm just good
at games at all but I'm very very oh no
no no I'm very very good no I am
extremely because I play a lot of
survival horror games i'm extremely
careful with how i use my inventory so
the boss fights were still pretty
difficult difficult but it all depends
on like how much how like many supplies
you saved up mm-hmm so i got to this one
boss fight and i was rewarded for being
there's a word like fastidious i guess
with my inventory and i could see how
other people have problems if they
didn't have six health packs made and
like 32 handgun bullets
or like that last shot gun shell that
ended up saving my life or something the
boss fights were actually kind of where
I loved it and also had problems of the
two boss fights of which there are
multiple stages they were way too
scripted at least one specifically one I
don't even understand why I died this
time and why I succeeded this time and
apparently there are branching paths
within these boss fights where this can
happen and this can happen but the best
boss fight that I saw of again there's
two people you fight but it's like six
different mini boss fights best one I
saw was just pretty much essentially
like the best of resin evil 4 or the
early ones where it just puts the boss
in this arena with you and you
understand what kind of space you're
working in and you're using the
inventory you've saved up and even in
certain points I was sprinting away from
this person which I was doing a lot and
then because I didn't have time to
search these shelves while she like this
person was chasing me I pop these
psychostimulants which like kind of
highlight items for you which that
allowed me to grab things on the fly and
then go to that they have a quick
crafting menu which again you just tab
over like I think our one or something
impressed make a health pack instead of
combined urban combine chem fluids so I
can actually do that on the I wouldn't
be able do that as fast on the fly
without those psychostimulants meth yeah
essentially it's just like a PCP
combined with coke and Molly and molly
is that what myth is not if no I think
ecstasy is like MDMA combined with math
coke or heroin it's okay we don't need
to go into this way oh sorry so much
knowledge none of that was true I've no
idea what he's got it on him right now I
don't even know like what guy lies are
for what I can say oh no I was gonna say
I'm rolling right now I'm not I don't
think you're allowed to say that no um
yeah so the best boss fight just put me
in this mini sandbox and just trusted me
to hit the right weak points and use my
weapons and their save room so you go
back to those and you like think ahead
like what do I need to bring to this i
know i need this key to get into this
boss room or whatever it was or um i'm
gonna leave the grenade launcher behind
for whatever reason take the shotgun but
leave the shells so i can free up space
for this health
inventory management and knowing
shortcuts that you've opened back to the
safe rooms was very you know like
survival horror as opposed to like res
evil four or five or six which is just
divided into chapters so you can't leave
items anywhere yeah you in the state
there save boxes in the safe rooms like
a rigid it does not constitute anywhere
that constitutes save rooms Oh anywhere
I thought you meant you can't at all
only in safe rooms yeah so residen evil
zero the remake I think yeah maybe was
in the original game I forget but they
yeah you could literally drop an item
anywhere yeah up later that was such a
good decision and I'm kind of
disappointed to hear that that's not
back yeah you think it would have
thought about that I mean I get it
because you're in someone else's house
and maybe they're there but they could
get in their own safe rooms can't pay
yeah you would have thought that you
could just like maybe drop an item in
this basement hallway you're trying to
capture that original feeling sure but
it even playing resonable 0 which went
for that as well but incorporated that
that shift sure well I don't know when's
the last time he played in the
traditional Resident Evil's Jake there's
have more recent ones I've just the more
recent ones down yeah so that was what I
was surprised I didn't see much
influence from those in this for hours i
played which I was expecting them to
kind of I guess the comparison made
earlier today was like they have a kind
of a difficult task with seven like just
like the force awakens did you have
people that grew up on four five six
resin evil you have people that grew up
the original trilogy and know how much
in general I think those are objectively
better as far as survival horror games
go obviously it's apples and oranges
when you're comparing to action games
but and then we're interviewing a
message chica kawada at Gamescom I think
and III and whatnot and then we
interviewed him in Japan again recently
we said like you kinda have to satisfy
two camps and from what he said before I
played he was saying we're not going to
satisfy everybody we just want to make
what we think would be a good game i was
like ok they're just you know
bullshitting but it does seem like they
just said screw it we're gonna go for
the traditional field just in first
person yeah yeah should really exciting
i would think could you see like maybe
closer to me and though this becomes
more action-oriented because it seems to
be like a typical sort of arc for you
dimensioning scripted boss fights sure
ish yeah there was so that you fight one
character and his fights are very
scripted then you fight another
character in that person's fights are
the better ones definitely it I could
see it kind of going off the rails
but I would I hope they kind of restrain
themselves enough well but while you get
more powerful it wouldn't be spreads
because you do get like better chem
fluids that can make like incendiary
grenade rounds as opposed to just
regular rounds or you know like just
better handgun ammo but you can also use
that to make like a full health pack
which would have saved you if you were
near death I also like I don't know
where else so i went to a greenhouse i
went to the shack i went to this camp
around the backyard and like kind of
around the swamp a little bit but those
parts were mentioned in these notes that
i found these little letters between
them they say like yeah he she died in
like the shack last night we need to
clean it up it's going to start smelling
so every place i saw was kind of hit
foreshadowed in these little you know
like diegetic notes and whatnot another
one mentioned this boat that was washed
up on shore in the bayou and then
another one mentioned this other place
and they didn't confirm I have no idea
but I'm assuming you're gonna go to
those places too because you're kind of
from what I understand from most the
game you're on this is state but it was
big like saying that is kind of like you
know like resin will remake you're going
between the guard house and then the
living quarters the cabin the the lab I
hope a lab I'm sick of the underground
lab which is in like every resident evil
I hope that doesn't come about this very
much reminded me of resident for as
opposed to you know it's not traditional
zombies and it's not like umbrella
umbrella corporations laboratory hiding
underneath this like innocuous place it
was very much just creepy foreign place
and this felt more like that to me I
hope they stay as grounded as possible-
the grenade launchers and minus the
people transforming into weird [ __ ] the
cure-all fluid yeah and this like like
miracle serum um it's pretty creepy I
they didn't rely on jump scares which
was nice it was pretty much this
constant dread because you would hear
this person stalking you on like this
side of the house to be like okay I'm
going to jump down the stairs here or
I'm gonna run down the stairs here but
also try to be quiet but if I sprint
right now I could get to that room maybe
it's gonna be a safe room I have no idea
but if I just crawl and just suck it up
and try to be you know brave about it
and I'll just get there safely yeah I
had like overall is I don't know I I
don't know where the story's gonna go I
don't know how crazy it might get later
on I can't speak to that I don't even
know how far into the game they didn't
tell us what chunk
it was um but it felt like a pretty
sizable part of it outside of safe room
so there any points where you felt like
the stocking family like wasn't a threat
like in a lot of buzzing evil games in
the past right I keep going to that one
room and be like oh it's just a puzzle I
know nothing's gonna get here so that
was actually cool they in the lantern
demo they hinted at this but you
couldn't do the puzzle unless um
Marguerite who was stalking you didn't
know you were there she knew you're
there it felt kind of cheesy like if she
knows you're there would be a like a red
x over the button that you're supposed
to press so it's literally game not
letting you but it makes sense I guess
you're in real life but there were
points where I hope it carries over like
I thought at one point when I was doing
and I heard the person coming which
would be awesome like you're trying to
like unlock some it's like that you know
that trope or someone's trying to unlock
and they're going through the keys and
the key ring while the person slowly
walking toward them it felt like that I
was like rearranging this item to in
front of a light source to make like it
line up and make a crazy shape on the
wall so I can get into this like secret
passage to escape them but there were
definitely points where yeah I felt a
little safer than I did like in the main
entryway of the mansion or upstairs in
the billiard room where forget what the
dad's name was um was just like kind of
wandering around searching for you with
his shovel his name is Paul Jacques Paul
Paul paw paw uh what was that joke looks
like a Paul I am I my back to texas
chainsaw massacre that i was so simple
and like that's how they refer to each
other's it's like the dog that came back
to tombstone sat down at the bar told
the bartender i'm looking the dog with
the bandage on came back to the to the
bar sat down at the bar told the
bartender looking for the man who shot
my paw butchered that joke take a camera
off of me out of here um what about the
sound design cuz that's pretty important
especially for like a first-person
horror game like you needs to be
believable it needs to be scary like how
was that yeah it was uh like I said
there were like these specific triggers
that started setting me off like when I
heard a molder forming behind me i just
started sprinting because i didn't want
I didn't think I'd have turned
to turn around and shoot it before it
hit me the in terms like I was saying
that you could kind of hear someone
mumbling to themselves or kind of
walking around on the hardwood floor
across the floor or across like this
wing of the house and nobody should not
go over there yeah um I don't even I
don't think there was much music aside
from this ambient stuff and like if like
if there were a couple jump scare
moments definitely where you know
scripted and it has to happen at this
point once you get this item otherwise
it wouldn't make sense there were a
couple moments where like it was kind of
an orchestral flare when that was creepy
if I was like tasteful though they
didn't overdo it yeah it sounded really
good especially because it was like this
pretty lonely place and especially we go
outside they just you you could
immediately tell it was like you know
outside like cricket serve cicadas or
whatever part of the cicada I guess in
that part of the country but it sounds
great from what I remember um I don't
know that it like particularly stuck out
though but I definitely drove home like
the atmosphere and ambience going back
going back to like the original feeling
I could III was like this reminds me of
PT now that you've played the game I can
Ernest does it does that comparison make
any sense at all anymore aside from
being first person and like this very
the rooms in yet it's a much slower pace
than like resin evils but you're not
it's not this psychological descent into
like madness at least now like PT
literally was you know you're spiraling
down or ever um it doesn't it's not this
kind of uh I didn't see that same like
familial disintegration like The Shining
or PT happening felt very much more like
a resident evil like zombies or kind of
eventually be going to become a thing
more of a monster movie then that
psychological kind of disturbing sort of
like even outlast kind of had PT vibes
but yeah I it feels very much more like
resident evil than it does a PT for sure
I don't know play it a lot of it but
again I don't know how much of the game
it was I mean well I was four hours the
game I think five total with VR but I
replayed one of the boss fight you don't
know how much
percentage of the end game that is you
don't know if you played a third or if
you played a tenth yeah this game and
like how much more there is to uncover
yeah I liked when you were saying
earlier about how you were getting keys
again that's such a familiar thing right
like these apparently in this one it's
like scorpion keys or various pieces did
it lead up somewhere like did it leave
you at a point or were you basically
like or did they tap me on the shoulder
and say your time is a lot piano like
did you get to an area so they had to
stop me because I think I was playing
the whole game I just think only let me
play a certain section from a certain
save point but I think I kind of
touching this and this is actually one
thing I did want to touch on I think
outlasted this really well you kind of
know what you have to do without them
like pushing you they kind of just nudge
you and say like there's a note says the
power you could turn on the power in the
basement and there's another thing
saying like obviously to use the
elevator to get up to the psych ward you
need to turn the power on us like [ __ ] I
have to go into the basement I don't
want to I heard something sloshing
around in the water down there I left
off at a point resin evil where I beat
this boss and I knew exactly what I had
to do it's actually kind of cool it was
one of those dumb puzzles that no one
would ever have in their house but these
people are crazy there's this scale and
there was a lantern on one side and then
you know it was it was off balance so
you like well okay well I need to find
another Lantern to balance that out and
then like where can I find ah [ __ ] like
Marguerite the this person that has been
stalking me the entire time is using a
lantern to find me so then they're like
you like damn it I have to go and
confront her now and that like they
don't ever say that like the character
does the same thing there's no note or
objective marker telling you have to
it's just like damn it like of course it
was the lantern demo like she was
carrying a lantern so at one point they
cut me off right there kind of when I
knew what I needed to do next just kind
of like in res evil 3 at the point
you're at right now great you're about
to leave the police station and you have
the lockpick so you know there's that
like rusty door over near that fire you
need to go to it's kind of like it you
know what your objectives without them
just outright telling you it just makes
sense which is really cool like I like
that kind of a like gentle nudge than I
do just like an objective marker
obviously like a follow and a call of
duty or something so I'm excited about
that um one final reservation I had that
I was curious about was you played it
regular you didn't play it in BR yes no
I play I play a little bit VR about tell
me about that because when I played the
lantern demo and V are very successfully
scared me multiple times was kind of one
of the few VR games where I was like yes
like I'm into it like this is working
really well and then in the scene where
they're feeding you all the parts the
guy grabbed me but in VR great like
nothing touched me and it immediately
sucked me out and I was like why would
you do that there's so many limitations
when you add VR to it did you have any
of those issues or did you feel like it
worked really well with the sound design
and the fact that I was planted in the
environment more I felt like the VR is
definitely worth playing and this is one
of those games where you can play like
an hour in outside of VR save it and
then switch over VR if you want and keep
playing that same playthrough from there
which that might be how I want to play
this game but i mean i'll probably play
a playthrough and then try VAR but yeah
there's a part where this one character
hold you up by the throat and so like I
saw the people playing it they were
looking down at him but yeah there's
still like a removal from him touching
you and beams scary it seems like a huge
risk I mean I I admire them for doing
these things like taking these large
risks you know the first person and VR
is such a risk for this series because
when something touches me in these games
i freak out mm-hmm but in VR my
immediate response is well that didn't
happen so I don't know it's like that
removal VR makes it feel like it is me I
don't know it's good that it's optional
I guess I wouldn't frame it as a risk at
that point just like an experiment yeah
like it's not gonna hurt anything for
being there it's just like what like a
way to market it to more people so it's
like you were gonna buy it anyway
because it's great and it's resident
evil but now in addition if you don't
even know if you don't care about
residen evil but you got this VR headset
and you're like [ __ ] I really need
another game for it yeah I'm sure he's
got one I'm sure Sony recognizes that
because there's like what nothing coming
out for PlayStation VR that we know
about like or that's worth caring about
except this game at the moment Samir
maybe that's part of it right yeah this
is a bit like weird for me too in terms
of like I don't know for like our site
right for games but you know if a game
is great but it like doesn't work as
well for VR like how we
and we rate that like I we talked about
it's not weird it's it's weird but you
know it's a case-by-case basis it's
weird Peter yeah from a wider
perspective it was creepy in its own way
from a wider perspective I was like I
really don't want to go into the
basement VR because it might I know it
gonna be less removal obviously like
that's the thing about VR it's the
obvious thing but yeah when you're up
closing this person supposed to be
touching your character and it doesn't
you don't feel it that removes you from
it and when he's supposed to be jamming
a knife into your mouth to feed you
liver you don't feel that others ready
for you so that I was thinking there
should be a service where you hire some
ways to say yeah you just have like
merry mess with you while yeah that's
called but like 5d that's good but yeah
from like got like being the basement
here in the water dripping on like the
you know the cement floors and kind of
hearing like more echoey and more
muffled upstairs I like that a lot and I
could see myself switching between VR
and you know like standard you don't
even you are good for audio no I know
but I mean like the way the audio kind
of envelops you in the setting i kind of
the cumulative effect sure the overall
kind of you know cohesion that I felt in
VR until someone touch me was supposed
to touch me do you think he'd be wearing
diapers when you play in VR as opposed
to normal yeah always wear my diaper
when I play games you first go to work I
guess maybe like overall though like
what would you say is your response from
this like do you feel like you walked
away and you were like hell yeah I do
have a lot of reservations and mean are
you neutral like what did this make you
feel like I have some reservations like
I said the scripted boss fights were
kind of worrying I don't know where the
story is going right now but I didn't
play the whole game overall I'm very
positive about it and I you know you
want to try to stay as objective as
possible during reviews and before you
seen a donor game what is it nope during
previews oh sorry for clarifying that if
you want to stand objective I've try to
like reserve as much a penny as possible
during previews I haven't seen the whole
game during reviews becomes too
that's all your opinion sorry reviews
editor Peter Brown that's your speaking
yeah downtown reviews editor Brown
anyway I'm pretty positive someone who
likes the older games and I like for a
lot i like 5-6 I don't love more like
but yeah I'm excited cool I think it
really January yeah generally 24th I'm
looking forward this is exciting if you
guys have additional questions that
people who are listening about isn't
evil you can tweet at us Mike McCarty
specifically who has played the four
hours I'm sure he would love to talk to
you guys about it and he's been really
good so far and like not just this
podcast we also have a man impressions
video going out and you're writing a
preview and Mike's been very careful
with not getting into spoilers so if
you're curious but you're worried like
Mike's been is going to be pretty
considered about that kind of stuff you
guys can ask a more specific questions
directly yeah now that this this is like
a big like last game of the year we
wanted to at least talk about well I
didn't release your obviously but now I
think we're going to get back into I
don't know movies because I think out
last two in the horizon I've been
playing Killing Floor 2 but we're kind
of up in the air but we're gonna be
talking about over the next few weeks
might have to delay a couple episodes
possibly because it's like gamespot were
doing a lark Game of the Year talks and
whatnot holiday horror movies man dude I
never saw we already said i never saw
Krampus we can I promise he won't do
that do you wanna grandmas all right
what's all that black christmas months
ago were you on the did you watch black
Christmas with us know we talked about
it i was gonna rent that i was gonna buy
the VHS we did a whole episode on it oh
thanks oh you know you did I it did I go
to Japan no you're yelling little circle
and the show uh we can watch die hard
that's a Christmas movie that's not
really scary know what it's cool Alan
riverwalk on a show bare feet I that's
Terminator 2 no it ain't that's
Terminator to die hard the one where
that dude made of Silver's like chasing
him though there's only one movie where
you can walk on
uh I got both alright anyway that's
probably the best place as possible to
end it rishi to say something Jake no
that was gonna say you didn't get me hey
did you laughed and sudden yeah it's not
die hard no I want to end it alright
cool i'll probably cut all this out
right and you don't got to go to Japan
switching to our new camera yeah as
usual you can email us dead air king spa
calm go to iTunes review us tweeted any
of us and let us know you think
questions comments concerns ideas for
future episodes and we're gonna get back
to letters from the Crypt at some point
to address read your emails we have a
few saved up we just haven't gotten in a
while yeah anyway as always thanks so
much for joining us and we were seniors
No
you